dans le sous-sol de cette église de
Montréal on offre des vêtements chaque
vendredi à des demandeurs d'asile ça
donne un coup de pouce à ceux qui par
exemple pentes
on fuit la violence en Colombie il
voulait donner un meilleur avenir à leur
fille de 4 ans
ils sont hébergés par Ottawa dans un
hôtel depuis un mois et n'arrive pas à
se trouver d'appartements
à 1400 1600 dollars par mois les loyers
sont trop élevés
social le problème c'est qu'ils ne
peuvent pas travailler les délais pour
obtenir un permis de travail ont explosé
six mois une heure on a des cas que les
gens ils savent pas jusqu'à quand avec
du record de demandeurs d'asile cette
année certains vivent maintenant dans
l'itinérance les centres d'hébergement
débordent c'est une crise humanitaire
des organismes communautaires ont
rencontré le gouvernement fédéral à
sujet ils sont en train de travailler
sur une solution de justement de pouvoir
émettre un permis de travail le plus
rapidement possible en attendant si les
arrivées continuent à croître on n'aura
pas le choix avec l'hiver qui s'en vient
des bergers de manière plus longue les
personnes qui sont pas capables de
trouver des logements là
en 2017 Québec avait réquisitionné le
Stade olympique pour les loger
temporairement il faudrait peut-être
envisager ce type de solutions à
l'approche de l'hiver ce serait une
solution là à court terme pour éviter
que ça parce que nous on craque vraiment
qu'on risque d'y avoir des des décès
d'ici est-ce qu'il trouve un travail
ion et Kelly font du bénévolat ici une
façon de se rendre utile et de rendre la
tente moins difficile ici Sébastien
Desrosiers Radio-Canada Montréal